hi my name is sebastian van teach at
Central University and the founder of
Udacity whenever I commute to this free
course fundamentals of self topic are we
build this with one of the intern joins
in China called pooja true you know Idol
has actually over the last years
developed an open-source framework for
self life card called Apollo and this
course is based on Apollo suit everybody
in the world who can build their self
that car now in this course you won't
have to problem it's very conceptual
please enjoy this class we built
inviting self-driving cars mark just
around the corner and if you're excited
to learn about self-driving cars maybe
even work with self-driving cars now is
the time Baidu is dedicated to making
self-driving cars a reality and this is
why by do creative Apollo open-source
platforms for autonomous driving
developers around the world Apollo
provides data tools cloud computing and
entire open source software stack for
building in self-driving cars now it's
possible for anyone to enter the field
of autonomous driving thousands of
people around the world have learned
about autonomous vehicles with udacity
and you should be next Udacity and Baidu
built a free course to give you a
comprehensive overview of self-driving
car fundamentals and Baidu's Apollo
software whether you're a senior
engineer were new to Java less
technology this course is a great way to
start learning about autonomous driving
join us in making the future of
self-driving cars a reality see you in
class
you